[Music]
there's something cinematic and painful
about it you're wearing a white dress
right with a man you thought you're
gonna marry and he sends you home in
tears how shocked were you and what was
that
departure like I did not see it coming
and I did not expect to feel so
emotional about it in that moment but
obviously I told this man I was in love
with him I was invested and I could see
a future with him so it was very
devastating to go through that this kind
of broke my heart you talked about in
your exit that you just don't feel good
enough why don't you feel good enough
because you're beautiful and smart and
wonderful where does that come from I
think that stems from past relationships
and throughout this whole process I feel
like I grew so much and learned so much
about myself and I'm disappointed in
myself for reverting back to that from
seeing that it made me realize oh my
gosh you deserve so much and you were
worth so much more than a rose at the
end of this thing I can honestly say
that it is one of the best experiences
of my life and I have no regrets
well plus-side a lot of people come for
you to be the Bachelorette how would you
approach that situation I think it would
be another learning and growing
experience and I'm all for that 30 years
from now I don't want to say well I'd
turn that down because I was scared or
nervous could we see you in paradise I
would love to be in paradise I would
love love to continue on this bachelor
journey so all the way to Mexico
[Music]